merci d'être avec nous encore une ferrée
et de nous accompagner pendant cette
première demi-heure c'est notre
socialiste du Calvados vous êtes membre
de la commission mixte paritaire sur la
réforme des retraites et justement on va
commencer en parlant de cette commission
mix paritaire est-ce que vous demandez
vous aussi qu'elle soit rendue publique
demain cette CMP qui se réunit à 9h mais
la demande a été formulée par notre
collègue à l'Assemblée nationale
président du groupe socialiste demande
formulé auprès de la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale et nous verrons
comment les choses évoluent vous le
souhaitez vous si c'est possible je
pense que ça va dans le bon sens de
permettre aux citoyens qui le souhaitent
de suivre cette cette commission il est
vrai que jusqu'à maintenant jamais
cet instant c'est ce type de réunion
nous ont été rendu public ces
commissions se sont toujours tenues à
huis clos ça ne risque pas de nuire à la
sérénité de débat parce que c'est pour
ça que ça c'est un peu sont à huis clos
pour vous il y a pas de risque qu'on la
rendent en public de nuire à la sérénité
des débats quand il y a transparence
tous les débats pour moi
pas comme on pourrait dire il y a pas de
risque dans la mesure où c'est
démocratique et où c'est donner la
possibilité aux Français d'être informé
de ce qu'il se passe dans cette
commission en particulier de secret mais
effectivement les parlementaires doivent
pouvoir échanger dans les meilleures
conditions vous aussi vous lancer un
appel à Gérard Larcher comme Boris
Vallaud l'a fait auprès d'y allemande
Pivet bien j'oublierai avec mes
collègues ceux qui l'ont naît pour cette
demande en particulier vous faites
partie des 14 parlementaires qui sont
donc réunis demain matin à partir de 9h
comment vous vous préparez à cette
commission mixparitaire bien nous
travaillons et bien évidemment avec ma
collègue Monique Lubin qui est notre
chef de fil sur ce dossier elle connaît
parfaitement le sujet et à travailler
depuis de nombreux mois nous y
travaillons avec elle bien sûr et nous
avons
développé un certain nombre d'arguments
pendant ces 10 derniers jours de débat
au Sénat donc je dirais tous les
arguments sont bien
oui affûté mais on pourrait dire pour
cette commission mix paritaire qui se
tiendra demain matin on va revenir sur
le fond mais sur la forme donc vous
serez vous sénatrice socialiste avec
votre collègue Monique Lubin c'est
Mathilde panneau qui représentera la
gauche pour l'Assemblée nationale vous
serez trois parlementaires de gauche
plus un RN opposé à la réforme les 10
autres sont a priori favorable au texte
est-ce que vous pourrez peser au sein de
cette commission d'expéritaire bien nous
ferons entendre notre voix comme nous
l'avons fait au cours de ces 10 jours et
nuit passé au Sénat indiquant que nous
sommes opposés à cette réforme mais avec
des je dirais des arguments très précis
des propositions également que nous
avons pu faire tous ces arguments
développés toutes les raisons évoquées
pour s'opposer à cette réforme et bien
nous poursuivrons ainsi au cours de
cette commission mix paritaire vous
discutez uniquement avec Monique Lubin
votre collègue sénatrice socialiste ou
vous discutez aussi avec Mathilde
panneau est-ce qu'il y aura une
stratégie commune de la gauche mais nous
avons en amont de ce texte eu des
réunions communes des groupes de gauche
de l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat et
nous avions travaillé je dirais de
concerts pour développer préciser nos
arguments pour dire pour quelle raison
nous étions opposés nous sommes toujours
opposés à cette réforme de la même façon
si on des propositions aussi concrètes
nous avons travaillé tous ensemble
demain oui oui tout à fait vous avez
parlé avec Mathilde vous l'avez entendu
Mathilde pano hier soir sur notre
antenne elle dit qu'elle fera le live
tweet de la CMP c'est à dire qu'elle
mettra sur les réseaux sociaux en temps
réel ce qui se passe vous êtes d'accord
avec cette méthode là je dois dire un
titre personnel non la demande elle a
été formulée officiellement par le
président du groupe socialiste à
l'Assemblée nationale auprès de la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
si elle donne son accord et bien les
choses se déroulant ainsi si Eli est
opposée on doit respecter aussi la
décision qui sera prise par la
présidente dans la République et de ne
pas être dans une organisation un format
qui ne soit pas conforme à ce qui aurait
été décidé par les deux assemblées il ne
s'agirait pas de remettre en cause je
dirais l'issue et surtout la décision de
cette CMP à l'issue de ce travail en
commun que nous mènerons demain matin
qu'est-ce que sur le fond donc vous
dites vous avez travaillé évidemment vos
arguments qu'est-ce que vous allez
défendre sur quel point vous allez vous
battre alors le point majeur c'est le
fameux article 7 qui propose le report
de l'âge légal à la retraite c'est
vraiment là la mesure phare de cette
réforme la proposition sur laquelle tous
sont opposés je vois évidemment les
organisations syndicales qui sont unies
depuis le début pour demander au
président de la République de retirer la
réforme mais particulièrement cet
article quand on demande aux Français de
travailler deux ans de plus 64 ans c'est
bien deux ans de plus que 62 ans calme
qu'il soit c'est à dire que que ce soit
des personnes qui sont en situation
comment on pourrait dire de carrière
longue je cherche le terme eh bien elles
sont même doublement pénalisés parce que
non seulement c'est le recul d'âge légal
à la retraite mais avec ces années ses
annuités de cotisations qui passent donc
à 43 ans une accélération de la réforme
Touraine donc quand vous avez commencé à
travailler à 20 ans vous y ajoutez 43
annuités ça ferait 63 ans sauf que l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite 64 ans
est-ce que c'est logique est-ce que
c'est juste c'est surtout cela
c'est un point aussi de divergence entre
les LR de l'assemblée et elle a l'air du
Sénat vous allez encore vous battre sur
cette question des carrières longues
pour que les Français dans un dispositif
de carrière longue ne travaille pas plus
de 43 annuités mais bien sûr il faut que
ce soit logique et juste encore une fois
logique n'est pas le bon terme c'est
juste pourquoi celui ou celle qui a
commencé à travailler à 20 ans et en
particulier puisque cette réforme
brutale va s'appliquer dès cette année
2023 toutes les personnes qui sont nées
dans les années 60 à cette époque
excusez-moi de revenir un peu en arrière
beaucoup beaucoup de jeunes commençaient
à travailler avant 21 ans beaucoup ou
même 19 ans énormément de personnes
elles ont pu avoir une carrière je
dirais complète sans difficulté sans
sans interruption pour quelconque raison
et pour autant elles devront travailler
et cotiser donc 44 ans alors que celui
qui aura 22 ans ou 23 ans sera limitée
entre guillemets à 43 ans c'est
totalement injuste
sur l'article 7 puisque c'est la
première chose que vous nous avez dit on
va se battre sur l'article 7 vous
espérez encore vraiment pouvoir changer
des choses sur cet article 7 sur le
report de l'âge demain matin mais
j'espère que mes collègues
de la majorité présidentielle de la
majorité sénatoriale entendront nos
arguments en tendron les arguments des
parlementaires de gauche que nous sommes
mais entendrons ce que disent les
Français ce que les Français rejettent à
90% ce que l'Inter syndical dénonce et
rejette depuis le début demande au
Président de la République à être reçu
ce qu'il a refusé prétendant que c'était
le temps du Parlement qu'il fallait se
laisser ce temps au Parlement et enfin
l'un n'empêche pas l'autre bien
évidemment respecter le temps de débat
du Parlement à la condition que les
choses se passent je dirais de façon à
laisser le temps de débat et non pas à
empêcher le débat et on pourra y revenir
bien évidemment dans quelques instants
donc tout cela il faut que ce soit
entendu nous n'avons cess de le dire
entendez ce que nous disent les Français
ce qu'il vous disent monsieur le
Président entendez les est-ce qu'il y a
des bonnes choses qui ont été votées
dans ce texte notamment au Sénat parce
qu'il y a pas eu de vote à l'assemblée
est-ce que par exemple la surcote des
mères de famille c'est quelque chose que
vous allez défendre demain alors c'est
une
oui on va dire ça n'est pas une mauvaise
chose voilà je cherche la façon de
m'exprimer mais ça n'est évidemment pas
une réponse apportée aux femmes qui sont
les premières victimes de cette réforme
mais vous souhaitez
adopté à l'Assemblée pardon excusez-moi
au Sénat je pense que les choses
resteront dans le texte à l'issue de la
CMP mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
c'est une mesure tout à fait
insuffisante au regard de la situation
des femmes des nombres femmes qui vont
être totalement victimes directement
impacté par cette réforme elles sont les
femmes en majorité sur des petits
salaires elles ont souvent des carrières
hachées c'est-à-dire pas non plus pour
différentes raisons elles sont plus
souvent sur des temps partiels imposées
non choisi et puis on va leur demander
demain de travailler à elles aussi deux
ans de plus avec elle montant de petites
pensions et j'ai oublié de dire que
elles sont encore aujourd'hui à travers
légal pardon salaire égal on en est
encore très loin donc cette proposition
pourquoi pas mais nous considérons
qu'elle est totalement insuffisante et
que ce n'est pas cela qui va permettre
de de rendre la réforme plus juste pire
encore social comme certains ministres
ont pu l'évoquer pour vous de cette
commission mixparitaire demain elle sera
conclusive
au regard du rapport de force comme vous
l'évoquiez tout à l'heure je pense que
les collègues de la majorité
présidentielle et de la majorité
sénatoriale trouvant un accord j'ai
envie de dire c'est leur réforme c'est
leur réforme c'est pas seulement la
réforme de d'Emmanuel Macron c'est aussi
la réforme en ce qui concerne le Sénat
de Bruno retaillod et de l'ensemble de
des sénateurs de la majorité sénatoriale
donc je ne vois pas comment il ne
pourrait pas trouver un accord si c'est
le cas il y aura un vote je dis matin au
Sénat jeudi après-midi à l'Assemblée
vous pensez que le gouvernement à
l'Assemblée nationale pourra se passer
du 49-3
j'ai envie de dire cela me concerne pas
directement puisque 49-3 ne peut pas
être utilisé au Sénat cela revient
à la décision du Président de la
République il emportera la
responsabilité ce que je peux dire c'est
que un recours sur une telle réforme aux
49-3 alors que le texte n'a pas été au
terme de son examen à l'Assemblée
nationale donc il n'a pas été voté à
l'Assemblée nationale au final faire
adopter cette réforme de force vraiment
on pourrait dire même au forceps en
allant jusqu'à utiliser le 49-3 et bien
je considère que c'est
c'est vraiment
je réfléchis avant de vous dire les mots
que je veux utiliser parce que on
pourrait dire c'est un déni de
démocratie bien évidemment le 49-3 il
est inscrit inscrit dans la Constitution
et on peut l'utiliser en tout cas
président de la République son Premier
ministre le solliciter il l'a fait
dernièrement en fin d'année 2022 sur
bon nombre de textes mais là quand on
entend la colère des Français il faut
savoir l'entendre et à un moment donné
vraiment ce serait très très mauvais
signe ou une très mauvaise réponse
donnée aux Français que de d'aller
jusqu'à recourir en 49-3 on va revenir
sur ce qui s'est passé au Sénat et votre
stratégie la stratégie de la gauche
sénatoriale pour ça on accueille Alex
pousse à
[Musique]
bonjour Ariane bonjour Corinne Ferret
bonjour
pour rallonger les débats sur la réforme
des retraites un concept est né
l'obstruction cordiale à distinguer de
l'obstruction radicale des députés
insoumis lors des débats l'Assemblée
nationale où il y a eu des attaques
personnelles non là le débat au Sénat
restait respectueux mais les sénateurs
de gauche ont utilisé de tous les moyens
réglementaires qu'ils avaient à leur
disposition pour rallonger les débats et
éviter un vote sur l'ensemble de cette
réforme des retraites ils ont déposé sur
chaque article à discuter bien des
dizaines d'amendements quasiment
identiques ou seul changer un mot un
chiffre ils ont également déposé et bien
des centaines de voir des milliers de
sous amendements pour amender des
amendements ce qui a multiplié les
prises de parole des sénateurs de gauche
sans oublier les rappels au règlement en
cascades alors forcément ça agacé la
majorité de droite du Sénat
effet répétitif d'amendement similaire
modifiant simplement un petit
pourcentage un petit pourcentage de
cotisations
supplémentaires et il y a des violences
déviance du débat parlementaire vous
n'expliquez pas votre amendement vous
profitez de la tribune pour faire des
effets tribunes parce que vous savez
qu'on vous regarde et effectivement les
gens nous regardent
alors la majorité de droite du Sénat est
un autre objectif à aller au bout de ce
texte et obtenir un vote sur cette
réforme des retraites et donc en
réplique au sénateur de gauche les
sénateurs de droite ont aussi utilisé
tous les articles du Règlement du Sénat
pour accélérer les débats articles 38
article 42 on en a beaucoup parlé le
gouvernement est aussi venu en aide à la
majorité sénatoriale en dégainant dans
les derniers jours de ce débat et bien
l'article 44 3 de la Constitution la
procédure dite du vote bloqué ça veut
dire qu'à ce moment là et bien les
sénateurs ne pouvaient plus modifier le
texte il pouvait seulement présenter
leur amendement et face à ce passage en
force du gouvernement et bien samedi
elle est sénateurs de gauche ont voulu
répondre par l'absurde en répétant tous
la même phrase regardez vous avez décidé
de dévitaliser la fonction parlementaire
par l'addition de toutes les procédures
que vous offre la constitution et le
règlement nous ne sommes pas dupe et les
Français n'ont plus ne lâcheront rien
vous avez décidé de dévitaliser la
fonction parlementaires par l'addition
de toutes les procédures que vous offre
la constitution et le règlement mais
nous ne sommes pas dupes et les Français
non plus nous ne lâcherons rien nous ne
les lâcherons pas voilà réponse par
l'absurde en cœur de la part des
sénateurs de gauche et samedi soir lors
du vote finale sur cette réforme des
retraites et bien la gauche est
notoriale a tenté une dernière manœuvre
de règlement pour rallonger d'une heure
les débats ils ont demandé la
vérification du quorum de sénateur on le
rappelle pour qu'un vote soit validé il
faut qu'il y ait dans l'hémicycle et
bien une majorité absolue de sénateurs
c'est à dire 175 sénateurs et si ce
n'est pas le cas et bien le vote est
reporté d'une heure mais pour demander
ce Corum et bien il faut qu'il y ait une
demande écrite de 30 sénateurs en
l'occurrence de 30 sénateurs de gauche
et au moment de la rédaction de cette
lettre il y a eu une faute de frappe une
faute dans les noms et le compte de 36
signatures de sénateurs de gauche n'y
était pas d'où les rires de la droite
regardez
après contrôle
il n'y a pas 30 sénateurs mais 29
[Applaudissements]
voilà on la demande de Corum a été ratée
par la gauche et 5000 plus tard la
réforme des retraites était votée par le
Sénat Corinne Ferret dans ces 10 jours
de débat au Sénat sur la réforme des
retraites et ce que vous reconnaissez
quand même qu'il y avait une volonté à
gauche de rallonger les débats et
d'éviter un vote finale sur le texte
alors vous présenter ainsi moi je veux
dire que nous souhaitions prendre le
temps nécessaire pour examiner
l'ensemble des articles pour pouvoir
étudier l'ensemble des amendements que
tous ont pu déposer à droite comme à
gauche et donc ce temps là il
appartenait au Parlement il nous étions
totalement dans notre rôle de
parlementaire que de pouvoir non
seulement débattre et proposer des
amendements vous avez évoqué une
obstruction cordiale j'ai vu que c'est
la presse qui a titré cela comme ça moi
je parle aussi d'empêchement de débat
parce que revenons on va dire un peu sur
la façon dont les choses se sont
organisées la première chose je note et
vous avez certaine avons constaté que
dans les premières journées de débat la
droite était étrangement silencieuse
étrangement silencieuse au point
évidemment ils en conclure que consigne
leur avait été donné de ne surtout pas
intervenir pour ne pas ralentir le débat
là on est véritablement ce que c'était
la gauche qui empêchait ou bien c'est la
droite qui empêchait et qui était dans
une volonté d'obstruction nous nous
avons présenté nous nous amendements
comme on le fait sur tous les textes et
nous aurions souhaité comme on le fait
toujours qu'il y a une confrontation on
est d'accord on n'est pas d'accord les
uns et les autres donnent leurs
arguments et on avance ainsi et on prend
le temps donc ça je le regrette et voir
je le dénonce aussi parce que c'était
délibéré et je dois dire que
j'ai trouvé mes collègues de droite
extrêmement courageux parce que ne rien
dire pendant des heures des jours et des
nuits ils font être courageux nous avons
joué et surtout rempli notre rôle de
parlementaire avec ses amendements qui
contrairement à ce que le rapporteur a
pu évoqué étaient des amendements
argumentés certes un certain nombre
d'entre eux ont été déposés par
plusieurs de mes collègues et nous avons
quand vous
reprenez le déroulé des débats vous
constaterez que les arguments ont été
complémentaires les uns des autres on a
une répétitions pas systématiquement les
mêmes choses peut-être à la fin de ces
10 jours et nuit longue au Sénat il est
vrai que nous avions cette phrase que
nous avons souhaité formuler chacun et
chacune en amont des arguments
développés sur les sur les amendements
parce que il y avait une situation qu'il
fallait dénoncer autant au Sénat que au
niveau national et
l'attitude on va dire du président de la
République nous souhaitions dénoncer ce
mépris qu'il exerce à l'égard des
Français et des organisations syndicales
il y a quand même des débats très tendus
sur le plan réglementaire à une bataille
réglementaire entre les sénateurs de
gauche les sénateurs de droite est-ce
que vous direz que ça va côté des traces
dans les futurs débats de la haute
assemblée qui est traditionnellement
étaient serein oui moi je regrette que
voulons à tout prix
accélérer si on l'examen de ce texte et
donc un signe empêcher encore une fois
la parole des sénateurs de gauche la
majorité sénatoriale dans un premier
temps a eu recours à bon nombre
d'articles du règlement intérieur vous
les avez cités au point que nous ne
pouvions plus
surenchérit on va dire ou intervenir à
plusieurs au moment des explications de
vote notamment et comme si cela ne
suffisait pas le gouvernement a aussi
activé le fameux article 44 3 pour le
vote bloqué donc on voit bien là que la
majorité présidentielle et la majorité
sénatoriale était main dans la main pour
empêcher l'opposition et les
parlementaires de gauche et les
sénateurs de gauche de s'exprimer et
puis et même je vais jusqu'à dire que
tous ces articles c'est les gars on va
dire
ne conteste pas ce que je conteste c'est
d'avoir recours à ces articles dans le
seul but de
d'empêcher la parole des sénateurs comme
si cela ne suffisait pas et bien des
collègues sénateurs LR ont même retiré
leurs amendements pour que les sénateurs
de gauche ne puissent pas intervenir
dans le débat et sous un mandé et pas
des moindres et pas des moindres puisque
je pense à un amendement du sénateur
retaillaux sur l'article premier qui
concerne les régimes spéciaux et qu'il
voulait déjà
amender à l'article 7 dans un premier
temps pour que l'application de cette
suspension des régimes spéciaux se fasse
immédiatement remarquer c'est dans la
continuité de la brutalité de cette
réforme donc dès cette année 2023 dans
un premier temps et il a demandé à
reporter cet amendement au-delà de
l'article 13 donc on est beaucoup plus
loin dans le débat et après
il a retiré parce que voyant que nous
étions un certain nombre vouloir nous
exprimer et donc sous amender il y a des
moyens de d'expression que nous avons
utilisé qui était tout à fait légaux et
pour pouvoir dire ce que nous pensions
de cela en particulier merci Alex à tout
à l'heure à tout à l'heure on parle
évidemment de cette réforme des
retraites dans le club débat de
sénateurs on va voir l'actualité du côté
de chez vous Corinne Ferret on va à Caen
retrouver Élodie Dardenne bonjour Elodie
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous chefs de
la rédaction de Ouest-France à Caen et
avec vous Elodie on va faire le point
sur la mobilisation contre la réforme
des retraites y a-t-il toujours des
blocages
oui bonjour oui toujours des blocages
depuis le 7 mars à Caen et plus
largement dans le Calvados on a vu des
villes des plus petites villes des
villes moyennes aussi touchées par des
blocages des barrages filtrants depuis
en effet depuis depuis le 7 mars
quasiment tous les jours
notamment au niveau du périphérique
Canet jusqu'ici tout va bien
il y a pas eu de tension exacerbée les
manifestations continuent à rassembler
aussi beaucoup de beaucoup de monde au
plus fort de la contestation
on a compté entre 25000 et 40 000
personnes à Caen
vous avez vous madame la sénatrice
défilé lors de des premières
manifestations cannaises et en tant que
parlementaire opposé à cette réforme
depuis le début j'imagine que tout cela
vous vous apportez pour mener le combat
dans l'hémicycle mais j'ai une petite
question sur alors qu'on arrive là dans
la dernière ligne droite que le vous
l'avez évoqué un petit peu avant mais le
recours au 49-3 est possible ne
craignez-vous pas une certaine
résignation des manifestants ou au
contraire l'émergence de tension à
l'image de ce qu'on a pu connaître dans
le Calvados lors de l'épisode des gilets
jaunes en 2018
mais tout d'abord bonjour voulez-vous
saluer
comme vous l'avez dit j'ai participé au
première manifestation parce que elles
étaient sur des jours où je n'avais pas
nécessité d'être au Sénat et ensuite
j'étais retenu au Sénat et
particulièrement bien évidemment c'est
ces dernières journées mais c'était très
important pour moi effectivement de avec
les autres manifestants de signifier
donc mon opposition à cette réforme mais
c'était aussi très important pour moi
pour pouvoir écouter entendre ce que les
hommes et les femmes présents dans ces
cortèges pouvaient dire aussi pour
quelle raison il s'opposait à cette
réforme je note que ces dernières
manifestations ont associé beaucoup
beaucoup de de personnes vous avez cité
des nombreux très importants à Caen mais
je sais aussi que des cortèges et des
manifestations étaient organisées à
Lisieux à vie à Falaise à Bayeux dans
des plus petites villes là où on avait
moins l'habitude de voir s'organiser
de des manifestations souvent c'est
effectivement le rassemblement à Caen la
ville centre et là on voit bien aussi
que dans ce dans cette
insatisfaction dans ce rejet de de cette
réforme et bien ce sont aussi des hommes
et des femmes que l'on ne voyait pas
forcément dans les autres manifestations
qui sont venus le dire dans la rue et
qui ont ainsi rejoint les rangs des
millions moi je le dis de millions de
Français en France au total qui ont
manifesté alors les choses s'organisent
aussi selon les souhaits et les
directives on pourrait dire des
organisations syndicales bien évidemment
les mouvements sociaux sont de leur
initiative donc il n'y a des
manifestations des cortèges organisées
il y a des rassemblements d'organiser
ici Oullins il y a je le vois je l'ai vu
aussi même si j'étais à Paris je suis
l'actualité de mon département au
quotidien grâce à votre journal
notamment
j'ai vu effectivement des des points de
rassemblement pour
interpeller sensibiliser aussi la
population que ce soit dans
l'agglomération de camp ou sur d'autres
villes de notre département on va parler
d'un autre sujet il nous reste une
minute et avec vous à parler de la
reconstruction du CHU de Caen
oui tout à fait le la reconstruction du
CHU a été lancé il y a deux ans
maintenant en février 2021 elle se
poursuit ça avance bien c'est le plus
gros chantier un des 20 dernières années
dans la dans la région un chantier à
plus de 550 millions d'euros
le ministre de la Santé François
lors d'une récente de visite c'est l'une
des l'une des plus vastes opérations
actuellement menées dans le milieu
hospitalier en France ce futur chute est
montré en exemple pour le futur de
l'hôpital public vous madame Ferret vous
avez souvent pris la parole au sein de
l'hémicycle en dehors pour défendre
l'hôpital public avant le covid il était
prévu de supprimer des lits dans ce fut
CHU aujourd'hui ça reste un point de
vigilance pour vous oui un point de
vigilance absolument je note que nous
avions été entendus lorsque
effectivement au tout début du covid et
quand ces choses ont commencé à se
préciser sur l'organisation de du futur
CHU l'idée
la proposition était de supprimer un
certain nombre de lits nous avons alerté
le parlementaires et je me souviens très
bien avec ma collègue de l'époque
Laurence Dumont nous avions alerté non
seulement le directeur du CHU mais aussi
les plus hautes autorités que ce soit la
RS et surtout le ministre de l'époque en
disant c'est une erreur ne faites pas
cela voyez ce qu'il se passe etc nous
avons été entendu puisque
le nombre de lits est revenu un nombre
on va dire suffisant tout en permettant
parce que c'était la volonté aussi de
l'établissement aussi d'être dans dans
une organisation en hospitalisation du
jour donc tout cela est aussi à prendre
considérations l'organisation en tout
cas de l'accueil et de l'accès aux soins
de nos concitoyens doit évoluer mais
certainement pas aux dépens de leur
santé merci beaucoup Corinne Ferret on
remercier Elodie Dardenne d'avoir été
avec nous depuis quand la Une de
Ouest-France quand Paris 2024 les défis
à 500 jours des Jeux c'est à la Une de
votre journal merci et le dit merci
beaucoup encore une fois d'avoir été
avec